is why i don't like aerosol spray  sunscreens these are the ones where you  hold down and the spray keeps coming out  the problem with these is that they  contain a lot of propellant which are  pressurized gases they're liquid inside  the can and they push the product out  this study found that a standard aerosol  sunscreen has about one-third propellant  but it can be as much as sixty percent  spf tests are done on the sunscreen  without the propellant so you're  actually getting about one-third less  product than it says one of these  bottles only has two or three full-body  applications some of the propellant also  lands with liquid on your skin so it's  hard to tell how much actual sunscreen  you've applied common propellers are  listed as butane propane isobutane or  hydrocarbon on the label